das neuartige corona virus mutiert sowie
alle viren ständig es passiert wenn es
sich vermehrt viren können das nicht von
allein sich vermehren sie benötigen die
zelle eines wirts etwa die eines
menschen der zelle schleuste das virus
seine erbinformation 1 beim corona virus
eine rna aus der zelle wird eine viren
fabrik die massenhaft kopiert neue viren
baut und am ende stirbt beim kopieren
von arena kommt es relativ häufig zu
fehlern die rna notiert teile von ihr
verrutschen oder gehen verloren
ein virus gebaut mit dieser mutierten
erreger kann neue eigenschaften haben
sind diese für das virus vorteilhafter
setzt es nicht durch von natur aus
völlig normal im augenblick wissen ist
das neue saas krone virus typ 2 nicht so
mutations freudig wie andere wären zb
vergleich zur influenza muss es auch
nicht denn es ist erfolgreich sagen
experten hat keinen grund sich
wesentlich zu verändern
dennoch könnte eine mutation auftauchen
die einem menschen stärker zusetzt als
ältere coronaviren theoretisch aber
natürlich es ist ein evolutionärer
nachteil wenn ich als virus bei der
vermehrung versuch mich zu vermehren
mein wird zu schnell töten die natur
geht in der regel andere wege bevorzugt
viren die iren wird nicht ans bett
fesseln
aber selbst wenn eine aggressivere
mutation bereits im umlauf wäre die etwa
mehrere organe befallen würde man könnte
das noch gar nicht nachweisen
das erfordert sehr komplexe versuche im
labor die dann wirklich sehr gut
kontrolliert durchgeführt werden müssen
um wirklich die frage zu beantworten ist
dieses virus jetzt infektiöser kann es
der immunantwort besser aus dem weg
gehen und das sind alle studien die ihre
zeit brauchen werden
eine veränderung hat man offenbar schon
entdeckt die frühere generation des
corona virus vermehrt sich in der lunge
eine mutierte variante macht das bei
ihren wirten woanders
im rachen ansteckender nicht tödlicher
was aber ist mit dem impfstoff wie
schwer machen mutationen ist forschern
einen lange wirksamen impfstoff zu
entwickeln
corona notiert zwar nicht so eilig aber
es mutiert
also es kommt ganz darauf an wie dieser
impfstoff auch ausgelegt ist ob der
impfstoff wirklich eine sehr breit
flächige immunantwort hervorruft und da
es ist eher wahrscheinlich dass das
virus nicht so schnell wege finden kann
dieser der breitflächigen und sehr stark
gegen antwort aus dem weg zu gehen von
dem was wir bis jetzt wissen muss man
nicht unbedingt davon ausgehen dass
waren jedes jahr neue impfstoff braucht
wie bei der influenza und das ist so ein
bisschen die hoffnung die wir für die
nächsten jahre haben
allerdings so bald immer mehr menschen
nach durchstanden der krankheit immun
werden könnte das virus unter druck
geraten sich was einfallen zu lassen
die forscher müssen also dranbleiben am
wandel dieses virus